all right so this is a simple guide to
secure s DLC which could also be renamed
how to build secure products so my name
is Audra Navarre I'm an application
security engineer at AppDynamics and I
break things to make them more secure I
really love doing it and if you want to
find me on Twitter it's odd SEC and if
you want to take any pictures please
send them to me because I would love
that
[Music]
so what we're going to talk about today
is security LC and all the components
that are involved with it so I'll bring
you through all the different steps of
what they are when you would start doing
them why you would even need it in the
first place and some tools so the tools
has an Asterix there because I like to
be as vendor and tool agnostic as
possible I'll give you a bunch of
options but it's really up to you to
decide what works best for the languages
that you're using and your company and
how hands-on you want it to be okay and
then we'll finish with how it all fits
together
alright so secure sdlc what even is that
I know it's acronyms and acronyms are
everywhere but essentially it's the
secure software development lifecycle so
you might have seen it buy a whole bunch
of different other names some people
call it just secure sdlc or secure STL
or I believe Microsoft is Microsoft STL
so it's all essentially the same thing
they just name different steps by
different actual names okay so it's
basically just baking security into your
product it all means the same thing and
it's a Multi multi faceted approach
hence the diamond but good news is that
it is there it's a partnership and it's
not entirely on you it's not entirely on
one person in general it really takes a
team so in this picture all the dogs
there are us as a team and we're pulling
the product across the line so that
basically leads to the first step which
is security training so security
training is really important because the
amount of security engineers to everyone
else in the company is
so far from one to one that we can't see
what's going on all the time and it's
really difficult to be able to bake
security and when you have a smaller
team and not that great at ratios so the
solution is to level up level everyone
else up so security training what it is
is security one on one 101 it's
basically going over some of the common
issues so you know generally what to
look for so you don't fall for things
some indicators I'm kind of like red
sirens when you see it you're like oh
okay I should probably check that out
and when you would do it so I
specifically do it with all new hires
just because all new hire engineers they
have this fresh outlook and they want to
know you know what's important to the
company and as security is something
that's extremely important to the
company you want to tell them early
maybe some of the issues that have
already been happening so that they
don't repeat the same ones so if there
are certain vulnerabilities that keep
coming up at your company or that you
know is legacy code you can let them
know so that they're not doing the same
thing shoes also annually so this isn't
something that should just be done once
it's a checkbox it's over it's something
that's continuous because new things are
coming out every year
so why as I mentioned it's a scalability
issue but it's also really good for
knowledge sharing I mean it's a really
fun topic and a lot of people want to
know more about it so the other great
thing is that it changes the mindset so
that it's not just okay security is
something that's a tech debt we can deal
with it later it's something that should
be addressed as it comes up and it also
changes the culture a little bit it's
it's kind of giving someone a contact to
reach out to if there is an issue and it
needs to be something that's addressed
immediately at least you know who to
reach out to as opposed to maybe
reaching out to the wrong email alias it
gets lost somewhere and never addressed
okay so an example of what happens if
you don't do security training a lot of
you have probably heard of what phishing
is so this is one of those low-hanging
fruit type things where if someone wants
to get through to your company they can
easily just send an email say from your
CFO to your CEO that says hey you know
I need these numbers I need them
immediately and you could spoof
everything you could spoof the headers
the email address that's coming from all
of it but if you have training for your
employees that basically says hey you
should look out for these things and
this is what you can check to make sure
it's legitimate then you're less likely
to be attacked this way and to actually
have it go through
okay so on the timeline you are here you
have this cool new product trademark of
course that you just can't with the idea
for and you want to begin you're like oh
my god it's gonna be this amazing
feature it's gonna change the entire
universe and we can't wait to work on it
so where do you start with security so
you're going to start with an
architecture review and you want to
start here as early as possible just
because these are the flaws that are
really hardest to change later on it's
not something that you can easily just
ship a hotfix out floor and be done with
it's something that involves sometimes
years worth of work so an architecture
review what it is is really profiling
your technology seeing what specific
things you're using maybe AWS lambda
anything new that's coming out analyzing
your attack surface so based on what
you're specifically using how can people
basically attack that and it's also
ensuring it's not vulnerable by design
so there are so many products out there
I'm sure if you've seen the other
security talks where a product was built
with all these huge flaws in it and they
rely on that and the problem with that
is that you have to come up with an
entirely new product just to fix what
was wrong in the first place so when you
would do it is product planning as soon
as possible really and why you would do
it is that a lot of vulnerabilities are
introduced during the design phase like
I mentioned before they really are the
hardest to change and this way you can
be secure by default which is basically
making sure that all of your default
presets are also secure so you're not
going in later and telling your users
hey if you want to be more secure you
can turn on this feature it's better to
be secure by default because then if a
user wants to use an insecure
configuration they can basically have
like a pop-up that says okay you are
being insecure by doing this the
responsibility is now on you and not on
the company developers anything like
that and this is the architect from the
matrix in case anyone needs the
reference
so the architecture review is to make
sure that you avoid things like this
where you have the best intentions
you're like you know we'll put a
security gate it's going to be all fixed
we'll have a really secure product but
you don't think about the other ways
that people can get around it even
though it might be obvious later on okay
so that leads me to security
requirements and this is mostly a
checklist so it's really the best
practices and it's tailored very
specifically to the language and the
database and all other specifics that
you are creating so it'll have like a
questionnaire that says okay if you're
using this this this these are the main
requirements that you should be thinking
about early on as you're building it so
you would think about it once you have
confirmed architecture once you know
what languages you're using what systems
features things like that and it's a
great checklist but the amazing thing
about tech lists is that they can easily
be translated into tickets which you can
then add to your sprints that you can
complete while you're building as
opposed to trying to add some security
items onto your Sprint's later on when
everyone is just super busy you know
you've got all these crazy deadlines and
you're trying to bolt something on
last-minute so and some tools for this
one of the tools is SD elements they
will definitely translate things
directly to tickets for you and one that
came out just recently is go STL it's by
slack and I think they just open sourced
it a couple months ago so I don't know
about you guys but I love closing JIRA
tickets or rally Trello version one
asana whatever you guys use I like
kicking things off it makes me feel a
lot more accomplished with things so
it's always good so threat modeling this
is starting to understand the attacker
perspective so it's really mapping your
assets all the different individual
things you're using that you might want
to protect the protections that you have
in place for those assets currently and
the different threats that would try and
attack that so it's really understanding
your threat vectors and I'll show you
why an example
shortly so once again you do it once you
have the confirmed architecture
preferably when there are data flow
diagrams because then you understand the
connections more and some areas that you
might want to start drilling down into
okay so this will definitely help you
lock down the easy attack pots it's also
a really nice visual for looking at
later on like say a couple years down
the line when someone is like okay how
does the application work and how are we
trying to how has it been secured
previously and what are the new features
that we're bolting on that might change
this and some of the tools are the
Microsoft threat modeling tool and the
OAuth threat dragon but honestly right
now I do this more manually because a
lot of these tools will give you a huge
huge list of results that you kind of
have to filter through and it's actually
faster to just look at it yourself so
that's my two cents if you absolutely
love the tools go for it okay so an
example of a threat model so you've got
your assets on the side here say it's
Batman and you've got his Batcave you've
got Alfred of course emails text
messages things like that and what you
have in place to protect these assets is
security systems the hidden secret layer
and some encryption and the threats that
Batman has is the police mostly the
Joker and journalists of course so when
you're looking at a threat model you
want to map everything out starting from
assets to threats but when you're
looking at the threat vectors you go
backwards so you look at the threats and
you say okay
of the threats which one is the most
likely to be attacking me and probably
the Joker because he seems to have a
penchant for Batman and he's probably
going to attack via the security system
because he's more of a smash-and-grab
type of villain and one of the things
that he would try to get to is Alfred
because of course Batman really cares
about all the people around him so that
might be a weak link so that's basically
how you would map the areas that you
want to make sure you lock down the most
because you're looking at your assets
and you're saying okay of all the assets
which ones are most important and which
ones can be at
via the threats and how to lock that
down on everything in between okay so
back to our timeline we've got this cool
new product again trademarked of course
and you have stable code now and it's in
a dev environment so what do you start
doing now so there's something called
static code analysis and this is
basically caching some of the easy bugs
early on and what it is is really
scanning your code for obvious issues so
it'll go through everything and say say
your feature is a new search field for
your product and you're taking all this
user input but you're not doing any
input validation you're just throwing it
straight back and then fetching it again
that is something that would come up in
this and basically have a red flag and
say okay for this specific line of code
you're not doing input validation these
are some of the things that you could do
and some code snippets that you can add
into it so you'd do this as soon as the
code is checked in preferably as soon as
possible because it's a lot more
difficult to go back later on and find
exactly what you were doing with that
specific area and bolted on it's also
something that you can easily automate
either in Jenkins team city whichever
one you're using and essentially it's
catching all the issues as soon as the
code is available and remediating it as
soon as possible so that you're not
introducing it to the new product and
one of the main reasons why you want to
do this as soon as possible as opposed
to later on once the product is all
released and everything is that you'll
have a lot less results coming up and a
lot less things you need to filter
through and you can start cutting things
off at the root as opposed to trying to
fix all these different areas and some
tools for this Barre code checkmarks
fortify they'll basically do the same
things what you want to be careful with
when you're choosing a tool is if they
support certain languages so there's no
one tool that will support absolutely
everything out there so you really want
to take a look at what you have
specifically and make sure that it's all
I'm going to work with the tool
okay so this is checkmarks it's one of
this diagnosis tools so just to give you
an idea of what it is and full
disclaimer this is a snapshot from
online none of this is internal to
anything that I've worked on but you can
see I don't have a pointer all right
well you can see on the bottom corner
here that there are 197 highs and
they're all recurrent and the great
thing about automating these scans is
that it'll tell you you know from the
last scan to the scan have there been
any new vulnerabilities that someone has
introduced to the code the other great
thing is that you can where is it go
next slide really the great thing is you
can drill down and see the exact line of
code that is causing the issue and fix
it there one of the other great features
is that you can start seeing which ones
have already been fixed and need to be
verified via another skin or which ones
are false positives and just not show up
anymore so it's just an idea of what
static analysis would look like so open
source analysis your code is only as
strong as its weakest link and I say
this again you could write the most
perfect secure code possible it could be
pristine you're so proud of it but it
doesn't matter if you add a extremely
weak dependency to it because then
you're introducing this huge
vulnerability to your to your codebase
into your product all right so what open
source analysis would do is go through
all of your code and pull out the
dependencies and the specific versions
that you're using this is really useful
because sometimes we forget which
version we're using sometimes we wrote
something years ago and we just never
thought about it ever again this will
pull all of those up and bring it to the
forefront and it'll also tell you the
known safe versions so in some cases if
it's something you haven't worked on in
a really long time it might be a major
update that you have to do but in more
likely scenarios it's usually just a
couple versions that you have to change
so this is something that you would also
do one code is checked in and you would
automate it again with Jenkins and
teamcity so that it just runs on its own
you don't have to think about it so why
are we doing this as I mentioned you
don't want to introduce critical
vulnerabilities and everyone's kind of
like yeah obviously of course you don't
want to do that but I don't know if
you've heard of the Equifax breach
so Equifax was this huge is this huge
credit reporting agency in the US and
they basically deal with a lot of fairly
sensitive information like Social
Security numbers which I believe is
called personal identification numbers
here a credit card numbers date of birth
a lot of information about you and they
had a breach where 146 million users
were affected and just to put that into
a little more perspective that's half
the population so every other person and
the entire United States had their
Social Security numbers taken within
this breach and the thing about this is
that it was a really easy attack it was
an Apache stretched vulnerability that
they could have found and fixed by doing
open source analysis and seeing that
they have this critical issue within
their product and within their
infrastructure so I really can't
emphasize enough how important this step
is if you don't do anything else at
least do this it's something that you
can set up super easily if there's a lot
of open source versions out there that
you can just throw into your code really
quickly and it'll light up like a
Christmas tree with all the red things
in my painter code there we go
so some tools that you can use for this
there's white source source clear and
sneak and there's actually a lot of
tools that have open source analysis
integrated into it that use these tools
as their back-end so if you use
checkmarks you can add white source on
top of that so that it's all in one pane
of glass which is kind of nice because
when you're automating it's just one
thing to do as opposed to two separate
ones okay so what does it look like so
again this is pulled from online so
it'll tell you generally what your risks
or is but more importantly on the bottom
half of this screen it'll tell you how
many issues the vulnerability the actual
CBE ID
associated with it and what it is and I
couldn't find a screenshot of the
further drilled down version but if you
click on that vulnerability it will tell
you the exact libraries that you're
using or dependencies things like that
and it'll actually give you the code
snippet to just do a quick diff and
change it all
so assuming it doesn't break anything
it's not a huge update it's relatively
easy to change over ok so you've got
this cool new product and it's now
mostly stable hooray and it's in the
staging environment so what do we do now
so dynamic testing this is caching your
runtime bugs as opposed to static where
it's just specifically the code so it's
automated testing and it's a black box
crew approach so for those of you don't
know what a black box approach is it's
basically testing something with zero
context of anything in the back so they
don't know about any of the code they
don't know anything about what the
application does it's just specifically
trying to find the easy issues so you'd
run this once you have the stable
product and the staging environment and
usually during QA itself so if you're
running any scans once your code is
checked in like using sonar cube or any
of those attacking this on at the very
end of it would be best because then
it's just automated it's running on the
back end you don't have to think about
it so why bother these are issues that
script kiddies exploit more often than
most because these are kind of like the
drive-by issues so the ones where people
are like oh why would anyone ever attack
us you know we're not this huge huge
company why would anyone take the time
or even bother and the answer is simple
sometimes it's ridiculously easy where
people aren't even targeting you they
might be targeting your customers or you
might just be a jump box to get to
someone else
yes
okay and some tools that you can use for
this are a wasp zap this is open source
burp and AppScan so this is in order of
price range half is free burp is mostly
free for the Community Edition the 300 a
year for the pro version which isn't bad
and apps can I don't even know what the
price is for that because it's not
something I'm willing to fork over so
pen testing this is my absolutely
favorite part this is the whole reason
why I got into security in the first
place because it's essentially hacking
all the things this is the fun part but
there's also a reason why it's at the
very end and I'll get into that in a
second so fan testing its hacking your
product basically like an attacker would
and you would do it definitely before
your product is released publicly just
because if you find these if someone
else finds these issues before you it
looks really bad in the media you get
called out it's really not good so you
would do this again in the staging
environment but if you like to live
dangerously you could do it in prod I
don't suggest it but you can do whatever
you want okay so I bother hackers will
do this anyway like I said sometimes
they just go for the low-hanging fruit
it you might not even really be a target
it was just really easy to do and you
might as well find the issues first and
fix them before it's available to the
public so one thing about this stage is
that if you've done everything else
before this you should not be having a
lot of findings here so you shouldn't be
having like 20-30 findings in a pen test
report it should be really only the
things that were difficult to find
otherwise so not in any of the other
steps okay and then some tools again for
this burps up in AppScan their proxies
that can test your product and an
example of say what burp would look like
so this is just with a scanner when
you're doing an actual pen test you'd
start using all the other tabs
extensions things like that but just to
give you an overview of what it might
like to an attacker if they're running
an initial scan on your website it'll
pop up with all these different issues
that are just immediate so they don't
even have to do anything at all to get
to this screen it's something that the
tool will do for them so when people are
like oh how did you find that that's
really hard it's sometimes it's really
not okay so there is no silver bullet to
developing a secure product I know it
would have been nice if I could just
give you an easy button and say hey just
do this one thing and everything will be
secure it I'll be perfectly fine but
that's just it's not how it works and
it's constantly evolving so there were
eight components that I went over
security training architecture review
security requirements threat modeling
static code analysis open source
analysis dynamic testing and pen testing
and the key thing to note about all this
is that it's not something that you
iterate through once and you're done
it's actually a cycle hence it's a
secure software development lifecycle
it's continuous and along those lines
it's also not sequential a lot of things
are happening in parallel so for example
static code analysis and open source
analysis you'd probably kick off around
the same time and they would both be
running every time you check in code so
it wouldn't be something that you just
do once once the product is entirely
done it's constantly happening as
development is constantly happening okay
so coming to the end here if you don't
do anything at all at least start with
static code and open source analysis
because this will give you the most bang
for your buck immediately if you start
with pen testing you might miss a lot of
the other vectors because the thing
about pen testing is that it's usually a
very narrow scope and it's usually a
time box approach so you might find
cross-site scripting or sequel injection
and a certain area of your application
but it might actually be prevalent in a
whole bunch of different areas you just
didn't test for it in those so if you do
static code analysis it will at least
pull out all the different areas so that
you can find a root cause that will fix
all of those for you as opposed to doing
fixes at different areas and then having
to do it all over again open source
analysis just because these are things
that a lot of people are hitting right
now because it's it's really as easy as
finding a stack trace that you're using
a certain dependency and saying like
going to Google and saying hey what is
an exploit for this and then copying
pasting that's it like it's it's really
a no-brainer it's also really great to
start with these because they're easy to
automate so it's less manual than a lot
of the other steps within the process
and then you can kind of build out from
there so if you start with these two
then move to whichever ones else that
are easier to get to
then you'd be pretty good shape okay so
with that I leave you with this super
inspirational quote about continuity and
how life is continuous and development
is continuous and so as security and a
cat telling you to follow your dreams
thank you if you guys have any questions
feel free to come up
[Applause]